In this video, I'm going to show you the
deep writing system that has helped me
become a number one bestselling author,
build an email list of over 5,000
people, get over 88 million impressions
by writing online, and launch over six
written courses. And in just a second,
I'm going to break down the four-step
system that I've personally used for
over the last 3 years that I guarantee
will not only help you write over a,000
words a day, but show you how to get
paid for that writing. By the way, I'm
Alan Drau. I've sold over $220,000 of my
own digital products by writing online.
And I've built the system to help me do
that while having a career, three kids,
a wife, weekends off, and a highly
addictive golf habit. Listen, I know
this system works and I'm going to show
you exactly how to do it. Starting
[music] with step one. Step one is you
need to write your why. You need to get
a pen and a piece of paper and you need
to jot down why do you want to start
writing more. This is [music] going to
be fuel for you when your motivation
drains out cuz it will drain out. For
me, it was always freedom and autonomy.
When I started writing a little bit over
four years ago, I was at a career that
gave me almost no creative freedom.
Everything that I created had to be
approved by someone. It was revised by
20 other people. And it just made me
feel like my ideas weren't worth [music]
anything. And then one random day, I
decided to start writing on Twitter
because I could post on Twitter my
ideas, my thoughts permissionless. No
one revised them, no one approved them,
whatever. It could just be my own. And
that freedom and autonomy has stuck with
me since I started writing. That writing
on Twitter led to me building an email
list led to me selling my own products.
Meeting some of the coolest people I've
ever met, and it completely changed my
life. So, that's my why, freedom and
autonomy. But what is your why? Do you
want to be a number one best-selling New
York Times author? Do you want to make
writing a full-time gig so you can quit
your job and stay at home with your
kids? You have to find the thing that
fuels you. So that when you show up and
you come to do the hard work, it's much
bigger than just I'm sitting down for 30
minutes to pen a,000 words. It's I'm
building my future. Which leads to step
two in our deep writing system and that
is build a writing ritual. I use
something called the pet method. I
created it for myself. It stands for
place, experience, and time. These are
the three things that enhance your
writing experience and make it more
likely that you will show [music] up
every single day. Starting with place,
you need to find a place that you can
dedicate completely to just writing. It
may be at your kitchen table. It may be
at your local Starbucks [music] or
ThirdWave coffee shop. Or you may order
a desk from IKEA that you build and put
it in the corner of one of your rooms
and that is your dedicated writing
[music] spot. That's what I did.
Whatever it is, you need to determine
what is the place that when I sit here,
this is where I write. This will trigger
your mind to associate that place with
that action to make the habit of riding
more natural with less willpower
involved. But that leads us to the
second part, experience. You can enhance
the experience of your riding by adding
things [music] that you personally
enjoy. For me, I like to ride early in
the morning. And so what I end up doing
is that is when I have my cup of
espresso. That's the only coffee I have
all day long. I take 10 minutes and I
pull a great shot of foamy espresso. I
get my big overear AirPod [music]
headphones. I turn on some lowfi beats.
I light one of my favorite candles like
a tobacco vanilla type candle. And
[music] those things have enhanced the
experience of my writing. Espresso,
lowfi beats, noiseancelling candle.
[music] It's a vibe and so it makes the
experience significantly more enjoyable.
So now you're at your writing desk. You
got the writing vibe going. Now, you
need to set the time. My friends over at
Ship 30 have something called sacred
hours. [music] And sacred hours means
it's the time that you can be the least
responsive [music]
and the most productive. For me, this is
typically like 6:00 to 6:30 a.m. Again,
I have a wife, three kids, I've got
other things that I'm working on. And
so, 6 to 6:30 a.m. gives me [music]
about an hour to 90 minutes to write in
peace. I don't have to respond to Slack
or text messages or email or anything
like that. The world doesn't expect
anything from me. These are typically
good times for writers, like really
early in the morning or really late at
night. But you can't just have the least
responsive hours. You have to have the
most productive. When do you have the
most energy? I tend to get a lot of
energy in the morning, but I know
there's a lot of night owls who get a
lot of energy at night. So, whenever
your brain is the clearest, you feel the
most freedom and you don't have the
obligation to to respond to the world.
That's when you're going to get your
best writing done. 2:00 in the
afternoon, when you're burnt and you're
already getting text messages and emails
and things like that, it's not going to
help you focus. You're going to be
incredibly distracted. Which leads us to
step three of the deep writing system
and that is obliterate distractions. I
have two very specific ways to help you
do this because you really only have one
distraction. That is your phone. Your
phone is your number one distraction. If
you can burn this to the ground, then
you will write more than you've ever
written before. In fact, these two
things to obliterate distractions helped
me write over a million words last year.
That's more than all seven Harry Potter
novels combined. Last year, I was
writing about 2,800 to 3,000 words a
day, which leads over a million. And the
way that I did that was by using one,
this app called Superfocus. So, on my
phone, I've installed it here, and it
actually has a section for daily writer.
I set a 2hour goal to write every single
day for 2 hours. And when I turn on the
daily writer super focus, it blocks
every single app on my phone except for
notion, which is my writing platform of
choice, and Apple Music, which I use for
the lowfi beats. everything else is
blocked. So, I can't even browse it. My
phone, my iPad, [music] my computer, all
of it blocked and it makes it really
hard to unblock it. So, now all the
scrolling and the internet and all that
stuff is obliterated. But I take it a
step further. Out of the million words
that I wrote last year, 70% of the words
were written on this thing. This is my
free right traveler. This is not
sponsored. They're not paying me to talk
about this product. I bought this
product with my own money. And it's a
typewriter. So, it's a really cool
modern-day typewriter that has a great
mechanical keyboard. And it does one
thing. The only thing that it does is
write. It doesn't have apps. It doesn't
have internet. It doesn't have browser.
It doesn't have anything. It has like
this e in display screen that looks like
a Kindle. You write on it, but it has a
direct connection to your email. So,
when you set this up, you can connect it
to your Gmail account or whatever. So,
that when you're finished writing, you
hit this little red button that says
send and it sends it over to your email.
So now you can write entirely without a
computer, which again is what I do 70%
of my writing on. I take this over to my
writing desk, my espresso, my lowfi
beats, blah blah blah, and I pound out
1,000 to 2,000 words just on this baby.
Then when I'm done, I hit send. It goes
over to my email. I copy and paste it
over to Notion, do my editing on my
computer, which by the way is a writing
hack. Edit on a different screen than
you write on. Helps you think
differently. And then I schedule it as
an email, post it as an article,
whatever I'm writing. that has
completely removed 99.9% of
distractions. You block your phone, you
write on a typewriter, so you're
disconnected from the internet. You will
write more than you've ever written in
your life. Which leads us to the last
step, step four, which is publish your
[music] writing. I alluded to the
beginning that I started writing on
Twitter and that Twitter account grew,
which grew my email list, which grew my
business. I never knew that was going to
happen. I didn't intend for it to
happen, but it did, and it changed my
life. [music] Publishing your writing
online is the greatest feedback tool you
will ever get. And you don't need
anyone's permission. You don't have to
revise anything. They can purely be your
ideas. So, if I were starting over, this
is what I would do. I would go to
substack.com. I would immediately start
an account and I would write notes and
post every single day. Notes is like
their Twitter feed [music] style social
media engagement form where it really is
like tweets. And then post is articles
like long- form articles that also get
sent as email. Again, they are not
paying me to say this. I'm not
affiliated. I don't make any money off
doing this. I just think it's a great
platform for writers. Especially if you
want to eventually get paid for your
writing because you're already doing the
writing, you might as well post it
online and get feedback from those
people that read it. Because if you have
a post that gets a 100 likes and then
you have a post that gets a,000 likes,
you could say, "Well, why did this one
get a,000 and this one get 100?" you
could start to dissect the feedback that
people have for your writing and you can
double down on what people want and what
is helpful for them and expand more on
those topics. It also helps you try
different hooks, different articles,
different segways, different writing
styles. You find your voice. There's no
downside to publishing your writing on a
platform like Substack, Twitter,
LinkedIn. But again, one of the reasons
I really like Substack is because
eventually after all that writing, you
have followers, you have email
subscribers because it's a built-in
email platform, and it has a builtin
paid newsletter option. So, if you want
to start charging for your emails
because you've gotten so good, you're a
great writer, you've built a following,
you are now getting paid to do the
writing you were already doing. You
don't have to change your workflow. You
don't have to add more work on top of
what you're doing. You could literally
turn on a paid newsletter and bam, now
you're starting to get paid. Let's say
you had a hundred people paying you $10
a month, right? A monthly subscription.
That's $1,000 a month for your writing.
Let's say you scale that up to a,000
people, which in the grand scheme of the
internet and all the things that we do,
thousand people is not that much. Well,
that's $10,000 per [music] month in
writing. And the beauty behind it is you
can literally write about anything.
Let's say you are writing uh a novel so
you can become a New York Times
bestselling author. You can document
your whole process. What's [music] your
plot, your script? How's it going?
What's working? What's not working? Post
that all online. Engage with people like
you and you can build a cult following
around your hobby of becoming a New York
Times bestselling author. You could do
this for golf. You can do it for tennis.
You can do it teach a business if you
teach AI. Doesn't matter. You can build
a readership around anything you're
enjoying in anything you're building.
That's the beauty of the internet. And
all of it can be done by writing online.
In fact, this is exactly how I've built
an email list of over 5,000 people in a
community on school where I teach
writers just like you on how to build a
2hour workday with zero clients so that
you can work less, enjoy life, and write
more. I hope you found this video
helpful, and if so, I got a few things
for you. One, I have 101 super sticky
hook templates for you. One of the
biggest struggles with writing is
getting attention, and the best way to
get attention is writing killer hooks.
Well, I've got 101 super sticky hooks
that you can grab in the link in the
description below to help you write uh
better subject lines, headlines, [music]
email articles, notes, everything like
that to get more attention online. You
can grab that down below. Also, while
you're at it, if you'd like to read my
writing, I write a daily email
allandragu.com where I tell stories and
I help you build a 2-hour workday by
writing online. I hope both of those
resources are really helpful for you.
And before you go, do me a favor, hit
like and subscribe to the channel. tells
me you want more content like this and
it supports me as a creator. I
appreciate it. Thank you so much and I
will catch you on the next one.